So let's just make
a little room here and
we'll copy this equation
down one more time.
But this time what we're going to
do is instead of considering
this weighted combination of
the Q values at state S prime,
weighted by the probability
of reaching S prime.
Let's just make it simple and
just worry about the S prime
where the difference is largest.
Since this is a weighted average,
or a convex combination,
it can't be any larger than
the biggest difference at any S prime.
So we're going to do that,
we're going to copy that down and
max it over S primes.
And we don't need to include
the max over a and S anymore,
because you'll notice this expression
doesn't even have a and S in it anymore.
So actually, by considering this kind
of worst case version we don't have to.
We don't have that max anymore.
>> And that gets us from
an equal to a less than an equal
>> This gets us from an equal to a less
than an equal that's right
because we're bounding it.
It could actually be a bit wider here.
We're considering the worst
possible next state in terms of
the difference between
these Q functions.
>> Okay.
>> And now you can see that it's
actually getting pretty close
to where we want to end up.
The main difference, in fact, let me
rewrite this max norm equation out.
So when we write that out we get gamma
times the max over state action pairs.
And I'm going to write s prime and
a prime to make it easier to
match up with the other equation.
It's however we're indexing
over the state action pairs
that make up Q1 and Q2.
So this max norm is really just the max
over those of the difference between
the two Q functions, and
this is where we are at the moment.
We have something like
gamma max over S prime, and
these maxes are trapped
in the absolute value.
It would be really nice if we could move
these maxes out of the absolute value,
and have it this way so
now the a primes actually match up.
Here this is the max action
according to the Q function Q1 and
this is the max actions
according to Q function Q2 and
it would good if we could just
talk about them together.
So this is kind of to me anyway
this is the most fun most exciting
most interesting step because
this turns out to be true.
[LAUGH] Right, that we can
actually move these maxes out, and
then we get a valid sequence.
So I'm going to focus in
on this step in a moment.
But let's just accept it for the time
being, that we can move these maxes out.
Now we've actually completed
the algebra that we needed to complete.
The difference between the two Q
functions after we apply the Bellman
operator is actually less than or equal
to gamma, something smaller than 1,
times what the distance was
before we applied the Q operator.
I'm sorry, the B operator of the
Bellman Operator of a value iteration.
>> Wow, so Bellman and
value iteration converges,
except for this magical step
you're about to explain to me.
>> Except for the magical step, yeah.
And the magic step is fun because it's,
I alternate between as seeing it as
completely obvious, and of course this
is true, and being completely mystified
and don't understand how
it could possibly be true.
And my brain just sort of flips back and
forth between those kind of
like a Necker cube.
So let's dive in and
make sure that this property holds,
knowing that once we establish
that we get the whole chain,
we get the whole
contraction operator thing.
We get all the power of
contraction operators
in when we're doing Bellman Optics.